шановні пані та панове
кваліфікована робоча сила для
відновлення України це проєкт німецького
товариства міжнародної співпраці і для
початку кілька правил поведінки які
можуть врятувати нам життя і
організувати
безпечну роботу в разі якщо лунає
повітряна тривога ми організовано
переходимо до підвального приміщення тут
нам допомагають цьому технічні
асистентки і асистенти на цей час робота
переривається але вона не припиняється
зовсім звичайно там ви зможете
обговорювати ці самі питання проте
трансляції не буде тому ми по-новому
роботу в повному обсязі якщо буде
тривога після того як пролунає Відбій
тривоги і це саме стосується тих хто
дивиться нас на
фейсбуку і Ютубі в Зумі хто приєднується
на час повітряної тривоги якщо ви знаєте
трансляції не буде Потім запрошуємо вас
повертатися
робочі мови сьогоднішньої конференції
українська та англійська українська
ваших
приладах для отримання синхронного
перекладу на другому каналі англійська
на першому і я раджу навіть тим хто
добре знає обидві мови послухати трошки
переклад тому що з нами сьогодні
працюють майстриня і майстер синхронного
перекладу Христина і Валерій Ну але не
відволікайтесь особливо
у нас буде чимало промовець і промовців
а після панельної дискусії
і в межах буде змога поставити запитання
почути відповіді і для цього У нас є
двоє дуже важливих людей це Євгенія і
Олександр Подивіться на них щоб потім
впізнати у них в руках будуть мікрофони
Майте на увазі що я дав їм суворий Ну не
наказ а суворо-прохання не давати
мікрофон в руки тим хто говорить тому що
потім дуже важко забирати цей мікрофон
назад Так що будьте готові до цього ну
що ж тема насправді дуже важлива вступні
зауваження які стосуються організації
роботи зроблено час переходити до
вітальних слів яких будуть звичайно ж не
просто вітальні а настроюватимуть нас на
плідну роботу першим запрошую до трибуни
Дмитра Завгороднього заступника міністра
освіти та науки України будь ласка
Доброго дня шикарно
ради всіх вас вітати тут знову радий
бачити так багато знайомих облич з усієї
країни Дуже дякую що зібралися Дякую що
ви є частиною цього проекту
в першу чергу я хочу подякувати нашим
партнерам і німецькому уряду і
Європейському союзу
джейзед і всім тим людям які роблять цей
проект можливо дуже вам дякую за це мені
насправді особисто достатньо важко
виступати на цій частині коли треба
казати якісь вступні слова знаєте не
відповідати на якийсь конкретне питання
або розповідати про щось конкретно А
всіх вітати але я хочу використати цей
час щоб сказати що для мене особисто
напрямок діяльності цього проекту є
стратегічно важливим дуже важливим і для
нашого Міністерства теж з двох причин
перша причина - це те що Ми
віримо ми презентували
прем'єр-міністру президентові України
на уряді що
наша освіта має
набагато більше роль відігравати в
частині освіти для дорослих перенавчання
для внутрішнього переміщених осіб для
ветеранів для людей які хочуть змінити
свою професію і насправді держава не так
багато робила для цього особливо в
частині Міністерства освіти і я
сподіваюся що ми будемо це виправляти а
друга частина - це
співпраця з міністерством економіки Мені
особисто Коли я прийшов на цю посаду і
став відповідати за
професійно-технічну освіту
ця ідея здалася стратегічно важливою
тобто більше співпрацювати з службою
зайнятості з міністерствами економіки
для того щоб зрозуміти як нам треба
змінювати нашу систему професійної
освіти до потреб ринку праці Я дуже
сподіваюся що ми всі один одному
допоможемо і цім цих моїх мрій досягнемо
дуже вам дякую пане Дмитре дякую вам
насправді вступне слово вийшло На мою
думку дуже стислом і тому змістовним але
якщо потрібні конкретні запитання то вам
знайомі обличчя це добре чи погано
з одного боку ви їх знаєте з іншого боку
вузьке коло а з іншого бокуща
вузьке коло Так це одна один з таких Я б
сказав недоліків навіть не нашої
зустрічі А загалом
Я вважаю що цей проект він мав би бути
набагато більшим над для того щоб
змінити умовно в країні щось масштабно
цього точно недостатньо і мені здається
всі ці розуміють але цього достатньо для
того щоб побудувати певні системні речі
які буде легше потім маштабувати і
значно легше будувати ці системні речі з
людьми які готові працювати які є тими
кого Я називаюсь знайомими обличчями
якого я рад бачити тому що це точно люди
які готові працювати І з якими ми можемо
досягти результату Дуже дякую діаметр
Міністерство освіти та науки і він уже
підвів нас до
логічного продовження Роман поклонський
директор департаменту праці та
зайнятості Міністерство економіки будь
ласка
Вітаю всіх присутніх Вітаю міжнародних
партнерів проекту
на моєму місці повинна стояти Тетяна
Бережна заступниця Міністра економіки
але вона на жаль захворіла і тому ця
честь сказати це вітальне слово воно
випало Сьогодні мені ми
Україна стикається з величезним викликом
з величезної гуманітарною катастрофою
спричиненою війною ми не знаємо коли
буде край цієї катастрофи і яким буде
повоєнний ринок Ми попросили зробити
Міжнародна організація праці декілька ще
організацій прогноз розвитку ринку праці
і ми отримали достатньо різні дані але
із позитиву те що всі ці дані свідчать
про те що ринок праці буде зростати він
буде розвиватися і для
повоєнного відновлення Нам потрібні
будуть кваліфіковані фахівці і от якраз
цей проект дякуючи
міжнародним партнерам німецькому уряду
jaz а
єврокомісії він
він буде сприяти він буде сприяти
буде сприяти
в майбутньому відновленню України він
буде сприяти перекваліфікації
людей І вони зможуть отримати нові
навички і нову роботу
значить я хочу навести приклад із одного
з моїх улюблених кінофільмів Список
Шиндлера коли
більше тисячі людей були врятовані одним
однією людиною це оскаром шиндлером І ви
пам'ятаєте Так коли була співбесіда
деяких цих людей і запитували Ви хто
піаніст і він стояв поруч і казав це
гарний формувальник так це ті
мікрокваліфікації яким
яких буде не вистачати людям для того
щоб вони інтегрувались Цей ринок
повоєнного відновлення звісно дитина
буде потребувати
багатьох багатьох
працівників для відновлення і у багатьох
із тих людей які залишилися тут або
повернутися після завершення війни буде
шанс за допомогою вашої програми тому
від Міністерства економіки Дякую вам
Будемо співпрацювати Дуже дякую пані і
панове Роман поклонський Міністерство
Економіки України Ну і тепер у нас є
садом він координатор кластеру сталого
економічного розвитку німецького
товариства міжнародного співробітництва
звертається до нас через Zoom
[музика]
шановні представники Міністерства
шановні друзі
учасники
розвиток
людського потенціалу України завжди був
серед потенціалу
Ми хотіли б допомогти Україні розвинути
зелену Україну
зеленою економікою в Україні
бо це країна у центрі Європи
Мені дуже приємно
бути частиною цього заходу З відкриття
нового
проекту
який виконується за підтримки німецького
міністерства економічного розвитку
проект
забезпечуватиме можливості підготовки
для робочих спеціальностей саме тих які
необхідні для відновлення України та її
економіки
оглядаючи назад на наші заходи з
допомогою підготовці
кваліфіковану робочої сили в рамках
проектів якими виконували з 2017 року
хочу сказати що ми надали допомогу більш
ніж тромстам птнз в Україні
ми забезпечили формування
матеріальної бази цих закладів надавали
ті обладнання
допомагали із складанням підручників
Таким чином ми
долучалися до розбудови України і зараз
ми посилимо наше зусилля залучаючи до
можливостей підготовки зокрема і
внутрішня переміщених осіб хочу
подякувати мінусовійти Міністерство
економіки за успішний початковий етап
виконання цього проекту Дуже дякую за
увагу
Ну і настав час представити проєкт Саме
цей схил створений і це робитимуть двоє
дуже важливих людей для цього проєкту
Міхаель Павло директор проєкту і потім
Олексій Олексюк радник проєкту пана
михайль будь ласка чи обидва обидва
зразу
котором сайт Доброго ранку і від нашої
сторони
нам завжди приємно бути частиною цієї
фахової
спільноти яка займається розвитком
профтехосвіти реформуванням освіти в
Україні хочемо представити сьогодні Наш
новий проект Skills Recovery і перш ніж
Олексій розповість деталі
хочу
таку Подорож у часі запропонувати щоб ми
побачили як все почалося
це сталося у грудні 22-го року ми бачимо
очільницю підрозділу Міністерства
профтехосвіти Ірину Шумик коли вона
розповідає про те як має відбуватися
відновлення
Це було під час обговорення з
представниками Міністерства економіки
служби зайнятості України на зустрічі у
Берліні тоді це було складні часи
щоденні атаки блекаути
Ірині довелося
пішки з 14-го поверху спускатися щоб
поїхати далі на вокзал і далі на Берлін
і ми вже тоді говорили про необхідність
програми такої як зараз ми говоримо
Skills for recover це стала основою
нашої пропозиції
федеральному міністерстві економічного
співпраці і розвитку і 9 липня
Міністерства видало нам розпорядження
про започаткування проекту це був
найкоротший період запуску проекту який
ми доводилося стикатися але хочу
подякувати Міністерство освіти роману
Завгороднього
за цю дуже ефективну швидку роботу ми
визначили 6 фокусних регіонів 14
основних професій і 20 пілотних закладів
які будуть охоплені роботу на цьому
заході хочемо оголосити що ми готові іти
уперед Дякуємо Що це стало можливо
завдяки вам
останніми днями мав можливість
подорожувати Україною
профтехосвіта це завжди про молодь про
їхніх батьків про викладачів про
дорослих які потребують перед підготовки
маємо також визнати що Україна зараз
знаходиться в особливій ситуації під час
зустрічі у Вінниці я зустрівся з Василем
тут у жовтні маєтці
який очолює компанію Аврора
роздрібнований мають
підрозділи по всій країні він говорив
про основний
виклик для них
проблема із персоналом частково через
мобілізацію частково через рело локацію
Він говорив про необхідність
перепідготовки і підготовки молоді
зокрема молодих жінок для того щоб вони
могли працювати у компанії
він дійсно бажає
налагодити партнерські стосунки з
надавачами послуг профтехосвіти
ще одна особа з якою зустрівся у Вінниці
Анна її компанія Perfetto виробляє
морозиво виробляє тістечка Вони мають
систему франшизи
їй довелося двічі лакуватись
за час існування компанії Спочатку вони
існували в Криму і були вимушені
переїхати до Херсону далі з Херсону до
Вінниця але вона не втрачає оптимізму
вона хоче розвивати компанію і очікує на
можливості партнерства з органом
організаціями які здатні надавати
відповідно підготовку робочу силі ще
одна особа з якою зустрівся цього разу у
Полтаві Катерина заступниця мера Полтави
вона працювала на нулі
бахмуті рік була парамедикам
зараз вона активно виступає за кращу
інтеграцію колишніх військовослужбовців
Мирне життя і саме У цей момент ми з нею
говорили про перспективи про техосвіти
для
колишніх військовослужбовців можливості
надання нових кваліфікацій нових
способів інтегруватися у життя Я думаю
що ці кілька людей вже демонструють як
змінюється середовище і як наш проект
може допомогти із тими змінами які
переживає Україна
загалом наш проект
виконуватиметься до кінця 26-го року
і кілька основних фактів про Україну
Я думаю ви знаєте це бо
Минулого року був значний економічний
шок падінням ВВП країни майже на третину
на 30%. але зараз ми бачимо багатьох
галузях відбувається відновлення при
цьому ринок праці досі не виглядає добре
найбільшим викликом буде
дедалі менше кількість осіб
працездатного дикого присутніх на ринку
праці через старіння суспільства через
відтік робочої сили більше 7 мільйонів
українців полишили Крим переїхали в
Європу і деінде
через збільшення кількості загрожених
груп всередині країни таких як колишній
військовослужбовці Я думаю що ці базові
передумови допомагають зрозуміти як
відбувалося структурування
структурування проекту з кілсфори кави і
наш проект фінансується міністерством
економічного співпраці і розвитку
Німеччини метою проекту є надання
підтримки або міністерством України для
створення ґрунтовної бази
щодо забезпечення процесів відновлення
кваліфікованої робочої силою
і кінцевим терміном виконання проекту є
червень 26-го року
ми визнаємо що головним фокусом нашого
проекту є підготовки перед підготовка
дорослого населення
для того щоб вони краще могли долучатися
до процесу відновлення другий момент
другий момент в тому щоб ми будемо
працювати із вразливими групами щоб вони
могли добре інтегруватися на
ринку праці що полегшать їм процес
інтеграції і також треба звертати увагу
на молодих людей в цій країні для кого
професійна освіта може стати
багатообіцяючою кар'єра нам треба
поєднати тему Як ми можемо
допомогти одночасно і
переміщеним особам і
брезгливим групам і молоді
та цього нашого проекту я зі свого боку
трошки також поясню про дизайн проекту
який дозволить Вам краще зрозуміти як
сконструйована імплементація і можливо
більш активно і ефективно прийняти
участь у розбудові професійної освіти і
ринку праці в Україні як повідомив
директор проекту Міхаель Пауло він
спокусований на таких ключових аспектах
але він має в собі дизайн який дозволяє
мультиплікувати результати цього проекту
який дозволяє сподіватися на поширення
результатів по всій Україні як ми
сьогодні вже чули що масштаб змін які
сьогодні переживає Україна економічні
зрушення змінили повністю всю систему і
також змінили суспільство суспільство в
регіонах а це означає що ці зміни мають
бути
адекватне оцінення адресовані
з іншого боку Я хотів би сказати що ми
маємо ситуацію яка створена історично і
сьогодні розвивається тому проект має
декілька компонентів починаючи знаєте
має свою таку проектну будову один з
компонентів спрямований на створення
передумов до емплементації тобто на
зміцнення надавачів послуг
покращення якості послуг тренування
керівників навчальних закладів центрів
зайнятості як працювати з новою
спільнотою з новим суспільством яке
створено в Україні з новими цільовими
групами другий компонент проекту
спрямований на
активізацію саме інновацій в сфері
підготовки тренінгових програм освітніх
програм і
після цього як ми створили передумови
розробили якісний освітній тренінговий
продукт ми переходимо до фази
працевлаштування сьогодні Україна має
недостатню ресурсів на освіту і
перепідготовку тому ми не можемо собі
дозволити
витрачання марна витрачання цих ресурсів
тому третій компонент - це ринок праці
підвищення транзитивності переходу від
освіти до ринку праці і навпаки з ринку
праці повернення в освіту і
завершує всю
архітектуру побудови проекту четвертий
компонент який за принципом знизу вгору
буде
формувати ті передумови Чи ті успішні
кейси приклади які далі ми будемо
адресувати на національному рівні і
спробувати змінити чи рекомендувати
змінити
регуляторну якусь основу і механізми
співпраці на різних рівнях В зв'язку з
цим
дуже далеко
вибачайте
на основі цієї архітектури Ми почали
рухатися разом з партнерами я хочу
подякувати нашим партнерам з якими ми
почали цей шлях і як Міхаель Павло
нагадав вам як започатковувався проект
Ми продовжуємо рухатись такий самий
логіці разом з партнерами ми провели
певну таку дослідження і визначили
сектори які є актуальними чи будуть
актуальними для України Ну звичайно
руйнування і втрати які здобула Україна
під час військової агресії це
будівництво енергетика з іншого боку ми
знаємо що
всі відчули втрати які зазнали в сектор
транспорту та логістики ви бачите другий
пріоритет третім пріоритетом сільське
господарство традиційне стратегічне
пріоритет для нашої держави і четвертий
сектор який важливо сфокусувати наші
зусилля це сектор сфери послуг чому це
важливо тому що особливо для людей які
частково втратили працездатність або
е-е здобувають новий фах більш прості
кваліфікації які не вимагають значних
фізичних зусиль будуть більш прийнятні
для працевлаштування виходячи з цього ми
зробили сьогодні вже крок далі нас немає
часу на як пан Міхаель сказав на довгий
процес амплементації і проведення
попередніх досліджень хоча ми їх зробили
якісно ми визначили разом з партнерами 6
фокусних регіонів Як ви бачите це
регіони покривають різні ситуації по
всій Україні і західні регіони східні
регіони а також центральні в межах
візиту ми вже побачили що в кожному з
них є своя специфіка різна кількість
переселенців різна ситуація щодо бізнесу
різні компанії змінили структуру
регіональних ринків праці
на цій основі ми
разом з партнерами спробували
спрогнозувати або хоча б домовитися які
потенційно
успішні фахівці будуть потрібні в
найближчий час звичайно ситуація в якій
сьогодні перебуває Україна не дозволяє
будувати достовірні прогнози але так чи
інакше ми визначили
шляхом воркшопів дискусії з двома
міністерствами пріоритетні кваліфікації
по яких бажано Ну будемо починати
рухатися звичайно зміни будуть
відбуватися в країні і ми будемо
адаптуватися до них але базова ми
спробували врахувати декілька моментів
перший момент - це відповідно групування
за секторами які ви бачили вище якщо ви
подивитесь на перші чотири кваліфікації
то це те що пов'язано з сектором
будівництва та енергетики далі ідуть
кваліфікації і які пов'язані з
транспортом та логістикою і є
актуальними наразі і ми це бачимо в
регіонах по дослідженнях і просто по
спілкуванню з людьми які живуть і
працюють в цих регіонах і ці 14
кваліфікацій також враховують певний
потенціал потенціал і новацій тому що
європрагнення України - це не тільки про
технології не тільки про обладнання яке
може бути завезено в Україну ці
технології мають бути імплементовані А
відповідно потрібні фахівці і на жаль на
відміну від того що нові технології
можна привести і ресурси можна залучити
людей треба навчити і це природній
процес його не можна ніяк
прискорити чи
іншим чином замінити і велика частина
проектів витрат проектів по відновленню
будуть складати якраз втрати на робочу
силу на кваліфікованих фахівців тому
напрямок руху України до європейської
спільноти він також передбачає поширення
знаєте цих нових цінностей і професійних
цінностей професійних стандартів
виконання вимог енергоефективності
виконання екологічності
соціального захисту та інше
Хотів би також Сказати що
ситуація в якій перебуває Україна
вимагала від нас і вимагає швидких дій і
як ви вже зрозуміли що в німецьке
товариство міжнародної співпраці почало
розробляти проект майже ну досить
інтенсивно зразу після військового
вторгнення на той момент вже було
зрозуміло що Україна зміниться і за
рахунок цього Сьогодні ми вже маємо
певні плани які напрацювали разом з
нашими партнерами якщо ви згадаєте
логіку яку Я пояснював як
сконструйований проект підготовка
надавачів освітніх послуг розробка
програм
імплементації або працевлаштування
випускників тобто освіта не тільки
заради випускника його заради дипломатів
заради робочого місця обмеженість
ресурсів вимагає просто від нас бути
супер ефективними щодо витрачання цих
ресурсів а це значить що кожна людина
яка навчена має принести користь або на
регіональному та національному рівні і
зараз на слайді ви бачите що
вже заплановані конкретні роботи Заходи
які
вимірюються не кількістю розроблених
документів а кількість людей які
підвищать кваліфікацію по закладах
освіти або кількістю
осіб які пройдуть перепідготовку а також
створенням основ для мультиплікації
тобто звернути увагу на третій блок
даної схеми це те що
сподіваємось посилить оцей зв'язок який
ми чули на політичному рівні співпраці
між освітою і ринком Праці а також
дозволить
відкрити можливість
полегшення переходу людей від освіти до
ринку праці і назад і останній блок
Також хотів би його анонсувати це певна
політична підтримка наших партнерів тут
ви бачите ті три елементи з якими почали
а також стратегічна перспектива освіта
це не тільки завжди про теперішнє це ще
про майбутнє це створення
нової країни відповідно зараз в першому
блоці Ми відповідаємо на запит який
існує в країні тут ви бачите і аналіз
ринку праці і
картографування
кваліфікації в певних секторах з іншого
боку також є вже ініціативи якими почали
реалізовувати з міністерством освіти
будемо долучати Міністерство економіки
щодо відповіді на запит ветеранської
спільноти або учасників бойових дій
і особливий блок - це репозиціонування
сфери освіти для освіти дорослих
звичайно стратегічні перспективи будуть
ще визначатися зараз бачите тільки два
блоки так що інакше я б хотів би
завершити цю презентацію трьома
ключовими речами перший момент що
досвід який ми здобули перебуваючи в
країні і
можливість
імплементації
різних проектів вони дозволяють нам
говорити щоб вже сьогодні треба
створювати передумови для того щоб
система професійної освіти була інша для
того щоб Україна була інша другий блок Я
б також хотів би сказати що відновлення
чи відбудова України це завжди про людей
це про людей для людей і іншого варіанту
немає я хотів би всіх вас запросити до
участі до
лучення до всіх заходів проекту для того
щоб ну створити гарний тил для наших
збройних сил і для нашої майбутньої
Перемоги дякую Дуже дякую пане Олексію
Дякую пане Міхаель і
ви можете вже пройти на свої місця
на дослідження часу не було сказал
Олексій олексив Я сподіваюся що успіх
проєкту
схиллсфорикав і буде предметом
дослідження предметом масштабування про
масштабування тутмів мову Дмитро
Завгородній про мікрокваліфікації і
різноманітні кваліфікації вів мову Роман
поклонський і про чотири компоненти Ми
почали від Міхаеля Павло і Олексій
Олексюка чотирикомпоненти - це як чотири
стихії які з'єднуються у кожній у
кожному з нас і в усьому чим ми живемо
Тому зараз
ураховуючи різноманітність того що вже
було сказано навіть у вітальних словах у
нас Панельна дискусія в якій обговорюємо
такі питання
чому формування трудового потенціалу для
відновлення таке важливе зараз під час
війни які три найбільш пріоритетні кроки
потрібно зробити для забезпечення
належної підготовки кваліфікованих
працівників і яким чином можна було б
активізувати чи підтримати вразливі
групи населення для їх участі у
відновленні України не справа модератора
втручатися у порядок денний і
формулювання але от щодо останнього
питання я все ж таки прошу зробити
редакційну вправу не яким чином можна
було б активізувати і так далі а яким
чином активізувати себто не умовний стан
Бо можна було б а можна і не було б а це
треба робити І про це нам говорили
керівники проєкту і представники
важливих міністерств які є політичними
партне рами як ми дізналися Ну що ж ні
ще не всі крісла поставлені Бачите як і
у нас сьогодні широке представництво До
речі та ще
А
сьоме буде чи не буде
не буде Значить я буду ходити А що
створює певні труднощі для організації
трансляція але я знаю що у нас такі
вправний Руслан на трансляції організує
що покажеться отже Я запрошую до участі
у таке принесли сьоме бачите обстановка
у нас змінюється просто щохвилини і ми
на них реагуємо там
так от
тепер у нас буде
ціла година на обговорення цієї теми в
кінці якої 12 хвилин принаймні ми
залишимо для ваших запитань відповідей
учасниці учасників а також для
реплік Ну і тепер Я запрошую до участі
Романа поклонського нагадаю директор
департаменту праці та зайнятості в
Міністерство економіки Ірина шумік
генеральна директорка директорату
професійної освіти Міністерства освіти
та науки пані Ірина Ганна Резник
заступниця голови Національного
агентства кваліфікації
денисулійник заступник директора
державного центру зайнятості Іван
Вербицький директор вседос
пана Іване є пане Іване і Наталя
Зарицька голова громадської організації
жінки зі сталі Ага моє крісло зайнято
нічого пішов на той кінець
у кожної кожного з вас буде по 5 хвилин
на виголошення
своєї заседницею промови і тези які ви
вважаєте за абсолютно необхідне
висловити А я буду нагадувати коли у вас
залишатиметься півхвилини до вичерпання
регламенту а для того щоб ви усвідомили
наскільки це багато 5 хвилин Зараз я
попрошу кожної кожного з вас в 30 секунд
відповісти на запитання яке ви досі не
знаєте от українською це називається
відкриття проєкту англійською
називається Cake off і went себто
початковий удар та спортивна
термінологія Але там є удар так от моє
запитання для кожної кожного з вас
звичайно цей проект протворення Але
творення часто відбувається за рахунок
того що щось треба усунути запитання по
чому треба насамперед вдарити
щоби ви могли добре здійснювати цей
проєкт і почне Іван Вербицький
раз я би вдарив по даних чи їх
відсутності щоб ми власне могли рахувати
і
розуміти наскільки ми успішно вчини
успішно реалізували цей проект і
досягнули поставлених цілей Дякую Ірина
Шумик
Я думаю що вдарити треба теж по правилах
гри тому що ми часто
боїмося змін або не хочемо цих змін і
дуже любимо фразу А ми завжди так робили
і воно завжди так було тому мені
здається що тут треба змінити Цей підхід
роботи в закладах освіти в наших
установах і це дасть результат Дякую
Роман поклонський
нормативно-правова база і
комунікація всі проблеми від браку
комунікації дякую дякую Наталя Зарицька
режиму окуня у чиновника це коли Та що
ви кажете ніколи такого не було І от
знову коли ми цього окуня розворушимо
все вдасться
Шановні колеги я думаю в першу чергу Нам
потрібно все ж таки консолідувати наші
зусилля для того щоб отримати такий
бажаний і необхідний для всіх нас
результат Дякую Денису Олійник
дякую Я думаю теж про зміну підходи
технології і боятися знаєте ставити
перед собою оці цілі якби ми повинні
досягти Отже удари зроблено поле
розчищено починаємо роботу на панельній
дискусії Тепер уже за тим порядком який
позначений у програмі по 5 хвилин Роман
поклонський Ви перший будь ласка
А ну почнемо з першого питання Чому
відновлення трудового потенціалу для
відновлення так важлива зараз під час
війни А це частина мого вітального слова
тому тут не складно ми повинні почати Хм
знаєте От ця відома притча так що коли у
джунглях сходить сонце то
прокидається леви і починає бігти коли у
джунглях сходить сонце прокидається
Антилопа і починає бігти Неважливо хто
ти у джунглях лев чи Антилопа коли
прокидається Сонце ти повинен бігти Да і
ми якщо прокинемось трохи раніше і
почнемо обігти то ми встигнемо якщо ми
Антилопа вбіг убігти від цього лева якщо
ми Лев то ми швидше знайдемо цю антилопу
і виконаємо свою ціни значить
відновлення
повоєнне відновлення ринок праці він
буде зростати він буде потребувати нових
працівників які повинні бути мати ті
навички які будуть затребувані ринком і
ті гнучкі працівники які готові будуть
змінювати свої кваліфікації
мікрокваліфікації вони займуть своє
місце на цьому ринку вони будуть е-е
фінансово забезпечення проти тих хто не
гнучкий Ми повинні створити цю гнучкість
для таких людей і е-е запевнити їх що
вони це зможуть тому
відновлення трудового потенціалу воно
важливо то есть той самий кіно який я
згадував там праця врятувала
1300 людей
у нас трохи інша задача У нас задача і
врятуватися людям і врятувати країну так
от якщо ми врятуємо цих людей то вони
врятують потім нашу країну в поєному
відновленні це з приводу першого питання
а три найбільш пріоритетні кроки
потрібно зробити для забезпечення
належної підготовки кваліфікованих
працівників це якраз швидке навчання
перенавчання кваліфікації
мікрокваліфікації якщо коротко у мене ж
5 хвилин а далі е це створення
кваліфікаційних центрів і якраз робота в
цьому напрямку буде вестися мінекономіки
ми попросимо допомагати нам е-е
Міністерства освіти і науки і
Національне агентство кваліфікації ми
будемо реформувати цю систему
централізувати її
Київський облік
більше більше подробиць поки не можу
сказати На жаль і
значить третє питання яким чином можна
було б активізувати та чи підтримати
вразливі групи населення для їх участі у
відновленні ну власне я можу озвучити
три програми які вже є Ми їх маємо ми їх
будемо
активізувати якщо не в умовному
часі це сказати це армія відновлення не
законодавчий термін але участь у
суспільно корисних роботах тих
безробітних які зареєструвалися у центрі
зайнятості і
на вимогу воєнних адміністрацій
залучення їх для будівництва оборонних
споруд і таке інше є робота це надання
мікрогрантів для створення нових робочих
місць тобто мікрогранпа 250 до 250 000
грн може отримати
працедавець який працевлаштує хоча б
одного працівника таких мікрогрантів
видано вже 4 000 на майже мільярд грн і
е-е
буквально два тижні тому прийнята
постанова Кабінету Міністрів про
допомогу роботодавцям облаштуванні
робочого місця для
осіб з інвалідністю тобто ті роботодавці
які працевлаштовують осіб з інвалідністю
вони будуть мати можливість
за
підтримки держави облаштувати робоче
місце для таких категорій Це буде дуже
актуально після війни дякую
Дуже дякую пане Романе пан поклонський
не лише накреслив те що вважає за
потрібне навів конкретні приклади це
чудово закликає інших
брати Ну слідувати прикладу п Романа
Ірина Шумик будь ласка ваші п'ять хвилин
Дякую власне Сьогодні мені згадалася
ситуація яка відбулася сім років тому
назад коли працюючи ще в департаменті
освіти Дніпропетровської області Ми
зверталися максимально До бізнесу і
казали колеги А давайте разом сядемо
подивимося покращуємо наші програми
Розкажіть що вас не влаштовує в освітніх
пропозиціях закладів освіти і на той
момент наші колеги говорили в нас все
чудово нам вистачає співробітників все
добре І ось я до чого я до того що
прогнозувати потрібно і потрібно завжди
так прогнози не завжди справджуються це
їхня особливість але принаймні є
можливість опрацювати різні
ситуації і до них підготуватися Рівно
через два роки ця велика кампанія це
металургійне виробництво звернулася до
нас повторно і сказали ой-ой-ой в нас
таке трапилося в нас Майже всі фахівці
Поїхали за кордон і давайте нам
терміново тут і зараз гарних фахівців а
так не буває для цього треба готуватись
І власне ми вже понад як півтора року
живемо у воєнному стані не просто живемо
з купою додаткових обставин я не знаю
яка країна Європи чи світу таке
переживала але що мені імпонує що ось
сказав Дмитро Що в залі багато знайомих
обличчя це і це дійсно це плюс плюс тому
що ми не зупиняємося ми рухаємося далі і
Ми якраз
в цій складній ситуації максимально
намагаємося спрогнозувати що буде далі і
ці прогнози стосується
окремі з них є очевидні Нам потрібно
буде відбудовувати країну ми вже її
відбудовуємо і вже сьогодні є потреба в
тих чи інших фахівцях нам точно потрібно
дбати про розвиток економіки якою буде
Україна далі Ну мені здається який там
сектор бере або декілька секторів це
більше питання до Міністерства економіки
але це питання до тих прогнозів які ми
могли на сьогодні робити задача цього
проекту буде підтримати
Україну і Ну спочатку окремі регіони і
загалом в тому щоб економіка нашої
держави отримала такі кадри
кваліфіковані кадри я часто не вживаю
слово висококваліфіковані тому що Вважаю
що кадри або кваліфіковані або ні Та тут
треба теж робити певне розмежування але
те що ми маємо підготуватися навіть якщо
десь не вгадаємо це нормально але якщо
ми вгадаємо у 80% це означає що це
правильно і це означає що Україна матиме
ту базу для того щоб в подальшому
отримати економічний прорив і
економічний розвиток бо інакше тоді все
наше існування і наша робота і наше
зусилля будуть марними тому я вважаю що
цінність і проекту і того що ми сьогодні
всі В цьому залі є надзвичайно великою
актуальною
панірину якщо йдеться про прогнози і
думаючи про прогнози погоди у їхню
основу кладуться зазвичай або наукові
спостереження і вимірювання там тиску з
швидкості витру або народні прикмети
назвіть народну прикмету яка вам
допомагає
А ну тут сьогодні вже про сонце встало
Та
я тут скажу словами своєї мами у мене
ранок починається зазвичай о 9:30
починався Так коли ще жила З батьками
коли відкривається двері і мама завжди
говорила сонце встали Пішли працювати
Тому у мене така собі народна прикмета
раз сонце кожного дня підіймається
високо вгору Значить ми
працюємо і працюємо на благо нашого
суспільства Дуже дякую а
гонорезник заступник цього голови НАК
коли я прочитав НАК то бувши більше
обізнаним у діяльності нафтогазового
комплексу я подумав що тут робиться
людина із знак Нафтогаз а потім
подивився виявляється не менш важливо
Хоча і менш відомо агенція але
докладаємо зусиль щоби про неї коли
сказали НАК Усі знали що це національна
агенція комунікації будь ласка
Дуже дякую
Шановні колеги справді питання які
піднімаються сьогодні вони надзвичайно
актуальні надзвичайно важливі Ми всі з
вами прекрасно розуміємо що майже два
роки ми живемо в умовах війни яка
вплинула абсолютно на всі сфери нашого
життя
маємо величезні руйнування матимемо ще
більше проблем і надалі але в умовах
коли потрібно відновлювати державу в
цілому економіку в першу чергу ми маємо
говорити про людські капітал коли ми з
вами говоримо про фахівців ми говоримо в
першу чергу про що Про знання уміння
навички компетентності які в першу чергу
і станом на сьогодні так необхідні так
важливі для мінливого і вразливого ринку
праці Я думаю що всі погодяться з тими
що допомагати державі вже потрібно Ми не
маємо чекати чогось робити потрібно вже
щось зараз власне багато чого робиться і
я хочу сказати що в умовах коли дуже
багато підприємств зруйновано ми всі про
це знаємо багато людей залишилося без
роботи
документи втрачені в нашому
законодавстві існує Такий механізм який
дозволяє присвоїти підтвердити визнати
професійну кваліфікацію власне як
представник національного агентства
кваліфікації звичайно я говорю про
кваліфікаційні центри які отримавши
статус кваліфікаційного центру проводять
оцінювання за результатом навчання і
мають можливість присвоїти підтвердити
професійну кваліфікацію а також визнати
професійну кваліфікацію отримати
отриману за кордоном що це дає ну в
першу чергу особа яка отримала такі
сертифікат і звернулась до
кваліфікаційного центру Вона може бути
дуже швидко працевлаштовано по факту
маємо дуже швидке наповнення ринку праці
високо сертифікованими працівниками
Насправді все ще простіше тому що
зацікавлена особа може звернутися в
такий кваліфікаційний центр подати
відповідні документи по відповідній
професійній кваліфікації закцентую увагу
на тому що така професійна кваліфікація
обов'язково має бути визначена
професійним стандартом особа проходить
процедуру оцінювання і отримує
сертифікат про присвоєння підтвердження
визнання відповідної кваліфікації І
власне може бути працею влаштована
Шановні колеги механізм роботи
кваліфікаційних центрів насправді
відносно новий тому що повноцінна
система у нас запрацювала на початку
2022 року
і станом на зараз можна вже констатувати
що це не просто сучасний А це дієвий
механізм допуску людей до роботи
станом на сьогодні в нашому реєстрі
кваліфікацій маємо вже по Україні 42
кваліфікаційних центри які здійснюють
свою роботу з присвоєння підтвердження
визнання професійних кваліфікацій аж за
155-ма професійними кваліфікаціями і з
впевненістю можу сказати що за два роки
успішної роботи кваліфікаційних центрів
присвоєно видано Перепрошую присвоєну
підтверджено і видано сертифікати вже
близько
1600 таких сертифікатів у нас Тобто ми
вже Скажімо так підводимо ту межу коли
вже найближчими днями ми будемо
отримувати звітування і отримуємо число
в 1600 виданих сертифікатів Тобто можна
констатувати що ці всі люди
працевлаштовані зі
з іншого боку Я хочу сказати що ми
готові
допомагати абсолютно всім хто цікавиться
професійними стандартами роботою
кваліфікаційних центрів Національне
агентство кваліфікації
гарантує інформаційний супровід
методичне забезпечення з питань які
стосуються розробки і професійних
стандартів присвоєння підтвердження
визнання професійних кваліфікацій а
також особливостей створення
кваліфікаційних центрів Шановні колеги
Дякую за увагу ми готові до співпраці
Дуже дякую і принаймні ваш прогноз на
найближчі дні дуже і дуже грати
а
заступник директора державного центру
зайнятості Денис Олійник продовжить
нашого обговорення Дякуємо Вітаю всіх
по-перше Дозвольте мені подякувати
за їх співпрацю за їх підтримку знаєте з
21-го року завдяки
підтримці ми змогли підготувати
близько 10 педагогічних працівників
наших цптоз створили відеоролики для 15
робітничих професій
отримали підтримку матеріального в плані
техніки та оснащення в 22-му році Ми
навчили близько 200 наших працівників
державного центру в сфері ІТ постійно
отримаємо обладнання там і ноутбуки
інших техніку обладнання для наших цпто
цей віртуальні
зварювальні апарати і оснащення для
наших станцій і ремонту там автомобілів
і багато-багато іншого і квадрокоптери і
обладнання для
сільгосптехніки тут дуже багато список Я
заберу часу не можу весь порахувати
стосовно служби зайнятості і наших
адаптації до сучасних викликів
Ми зараз
намагаємось трансформувати і
знаєте Вплинути з часом за підтримки
Міністерства економіки казав пан Роман в
нас є багато активних програм Це дійсно
там і мікрогранти на власну справу 250
тисяч і підтримка ветеранів гранти до
мільйона і це навчання вже видано майже
13 тисяч ваучерів для навчання
ми розуміємо бо ситуація яка
відбувається на ринку праці зараз
майже 72% це жінки 28 відсотків це
чоловіки які стоять на обліку в службі
зайнятості
104 тисячі
безробітних але ми рухаємося ми чуємо
роботодавців і намагаємося змінити
підхід зараз в нас навіть змінюється
технологія Ми більше розвертаємося в бік
роботодавців ми будемо намагатися
відправляти до роботодавців виключно
вмотивованих людей які хочуть працювати
і бажають це робити в нас пройшли
навчання в наших е-е центрах
профтехосвіти на сьогодні більше вже 12
тисяч осіб майже 8 тисяч осіб прийшли
навчання на базах роботодавців
і також ми розуміємо що сьогодні коли
буде повернення наших е-е жінок та
хлопців в наших ветеранів після
реабілітації підтримки навчання при
навчанні безпосередньо служба зайнятості
повинна поставити крапкових соціальній
адаптації це надання роботи тому що коли
людина отримує роботу
вона би буде соціальна адаптована і
готова до мирного життя і відновлення
нашої держави дякую Дуже дякую пане
Денисе я не сумніваюсь що про
реабілітацію і про ветеранів всього
говорити в мене Наталія Зарицька але з
першого
на відміну від представників державних
структур послухаємо представника
аналітичного незалежного позапартійного
центру садоз Іван Вербицький будь ласка
та Дякую ми справді проводимо
дослідження і працюємо над різними
проектами місцевого розвитку і
відповідаючи на питання Чому чи Навіщо
нам потрібні власник кваліфіковані кадри
тут мені хочеться говорити в першу чергу
про людську гідність і про можливість
для кожної людини реалізувати себе в
житті забезпечити свій добробут і
вочевидь саме кваліфікації робота
зайнятість так підвищення продуктивності
в країні це ключі до того щоби ми
досягнули цієї цілі гідного життя для
кожної людини ми знаємо також що 71%
людей в Україні готові змінити професію
якщо це буде потрібно і навчитися
отримати якісь нові навички і знання
власне для того щоб знайти собі роботу і
власне ціла наше завдання ціле завдання
цього проекту надати можливість цим
людям власне зробити це так мати
можливість отримати навчання при
кваліфікацію
мені хочеться закцентувати зараз на
кількох важливих речах в першу чергу це
про систему збору даних досліджень
індикаторів Так про що вже згадував дуже
важливо це і стосовно професійної освіти
і стосовно власне політики у сфері
зайнятості яку держава впроваджує
ефективності роботи державної служби
зайнятості в тому числі власне
удосконалення того які дані ми збираємо
яким чином щоб ми знаємо про те чому
людина наприклад вибирають
професійно-технічну освіту в Україні
Чому вони не вибирають її яким чином
люди будуть свої кар'єрні шляхи власне
як змінюється уявлення про професійну
освіту це дуже важливо для того щоб ми
могли власне планувати ці політики і
інтервенції і впроваджувати такі проекти
як цей
мені важливо також згадати про питання
гендерної рівності оскільки саме
професійна освіта це той рівень освіти
де ми маємо найменше гендерної рівності
рівності між чоловіками і жінками і це ж
питання яке може бути адресоване власне
державної політикою яка може бути
адресоване в школах що власне важливо
для до того як Люди приходять до
професійної освіти і це те питання над
якими ми можемо працювати важливо також
говорити про те яким чином відбувалося
навчання І власне отримання кваліфікації
впродовж останніх років та і це час коли
ми вчилися багато коли дистанційно і ми
розуміємо що дистанційне навчання під
час масштабного вторгнення вплинуло на
те які навички здобули чи втратили не
здобули власне люди які навчалися і це
теж один з викликів який буде потрібно
подолати Коли вони будуть виходити на
ринок праці
Я також хочу згадати питання яке
стосується психо політичної допомоги це
те що ми працюємо зараз у всій країні у
всіх таймах у всіх закладах у всіх
організаціях але очевидно коли ми
говоримо про професійну освіту то і про
отримання кваліфікації то власне
самозрадність психологічна в тому числі
Я дуже важливою нам важливо також
говорити про фізичну безбар'єрність коли
ми говоримо про здобуття професійних
навичок і професійного світу оскільки це
теж буде одним з одним з викликів з
якими ми будемо стикатися в цій країні
коли ми говоримо про власне те яким
чином держава держава дає собі раду чи
планує давати Раду з питаннями
безробіття з питаннями працевлаштування
звісно Плани є дуже важливі ми знаємо
про те що як казали попередні доповідачі
У нас є багато прекрасних програм які
вже впроваджуються і будуть
впроваджуватися надалі дуже важливо
власне
з моєю перспективи так з нашою
перспективи те що ми бачимо це власне
більше конкурсу на навчання і
перекваліфікацію Тобто ви згадували
програмував через Очевидно це те щоби ми
рекомендували найбільше розвивати
розширювати давати більше можливості
більшим кількості людей здобувати різні
навички які їм потрібні І власне
проходити цю кваліфікацію для закладів
освіти створювати такі програми
короткотривалі програми щоб люди могли
здобувати цю компетенції які їм потрібні
ті компетенції які потрібні ринку праці
і власне отримувати гідну роботу
економіка буде отримувати кваліфікованих
працівників наша держава буде отримувати
зростання продуктивності це власне Те
чим планує працювати цей проект І це те
що з нашої перспективи власне є ключовим
для розвитку України після воєнного
відновлення зараз Дякую
Дякую Шановні колеги кому видається
недостатнім те що тут сказав Іван
Вербицький і що він ще скажу відповідь
як на запитання рекомендую вам сайт все
дот.orgot.ua там багато дуже цікавих
матеріалів на дотичну тематику ну і
зараз Наталія Вербицька яка тут
зазначена Як голова
громадської організації жінки за сталі я
вам скажу вона не лише голова цієї
організації Вона ще й серце цей
організації тому будьте готові будь
ласка
Дякую пане Андрія за така представлення
Ми з паном Андрієм познайомилися в газі
коли пан Андрій модерував нашу дискусію
щодо зниклих безвісти полонених а
постраждалих у цій війні
я дійсно очолюю цю організацію є
дружиною військовослужбовця який 9 років
відвоював прийшов
Опитне заєць в
світлодарську дугу маріупольську
компанію був на азовсталі в пеклі полону
А зараз знаходиться в бюрократичному
пеклі він має три дні народження
на свій власний 21 вересня коли його
звільнили з полону і 11 вересня коли він
звільнився з військової служби
і ось кілька днів як безробітної
вочевидь буде клієнтом
державної служби і центру зайнятості
що я хочу сказати Я хочу запитати Хто
стріляв з
автоматичною зброєю в залі
Та є кілька людей які розуміють що таке
віддача
і якщо ти не готовий до віддачі
де куди тебе може серйозна поранити і з
поверненням ветеранів ми отримуємо наше
суспільство отримає колосальну віддачу
до якої треба підготуватися
навіть у такій благонадійній
процвітаючій країні як Сполучені Штати
після в'єтнамської війни вони
зіштовхнулися з колосальною катастрофою
коли
за статистикою 50% людей які бачать
перед собою безхатька думають що це
ветерано обґрунтовано так вважають
і на сьогодні повернуться хлопці і
дівчата Ну давайте назвемо це своїми
іменами це навчені вбивці
деморалізовані і зі зруйнованою психікою
у яких на першому місці буде взагалі
стояти виживання а вже потім десь на
10-му місці освіта якщо брати траєкторію
бійця ветерана його потрапляння у важкі
бойові дії
че поранення чи полон далі повернення
додому має бути реабілітація на сьогодні
я підміна поняття не має в Україні
реабілітації є швидко підставили плече
вилікували але реабілітація не може бути
два тижні в шестимісні палаті з іншими
пораненими
тому отут буде прогалина але в
ідеальному світі після цієї реабілітації
людина має реінтегруватися в суспільство
і потім
ресоціалізуватися і отримати освіту
при цьому ось якщо ми говоримо за армію
яка буде відбудовувати
у людини немає тумблера рубильника що
ось сьогодні він мобілізується на захист
країни а тут раз повернувся переключили
рубильники і він буде все відбудовувати
на жаль так не буде це ілюзія на
сьогодні хлопці і дівчата які
повернулися на жаль є статистика по
суїцидам і це не тільки в нашій країні
це усіх країнах які переживали війни
вони не можуть втриматися у сім'ї це
розлучення вони не можуть втриматися на
роботі я не знаю як вони втримаються за
партою у вищому навчальному закладі про
або професійно-технічному закладі а тим
більше якщо в цій аудиторії Ну так
склалося що
В мене є 10 років
стажу вищому навчальному закладі і я
розумію що на сьогодні у нас ухилянти
прийшли і сіли за Лави навчальні
здобувають другу вищу освіту якщо сюди
прийде сяде Ветеран за таку парту це
буде конфлікт в одній аудиторії в межах
одного навчального закладу
і тут вочевидь нам треба говорити там е
про педагогічного геронтологію і про
підготовку фахівців і я дуже рада я
дякую проекту giss
giz так що ви підтримуєте і ви
висвітлюєте цю проблему
бо на сьогодні паралельно ми говоримо
про підготовку роботодавців до
повернення А ще треба готувати освітні
заклади для повернення
і в тому бюрократичному пеклі про яке я
згадала ну солдату по-перше треба
активноде 5 службове розслідування про
отриману травму готувати відновлювати
документи у нас на сьогодні взагалі в
держава не знаю хто такі Ветеран і
Міністерство у справах ветеранів там на
якомусь етапі створення реєстру кажуть
що створено але коли відкриваєш
законного проекту що там має бути То ми
розуміємо що ми не знаємо хто такий
ветеран
і Ветеран На жаль немає єдиної точки
збору Куди він може звернутися прийти і
отримати послугу
і
сьогодні хто такий ветеран
сьогодні боєць він або на лікарняному
ліжку або в окопі інакшого не дано і на
сьогодні освіту може отримати вже такий
боєць який не може стати до
служби військової Це або ампутант або
паралізована людина або дуже зранена
психічно
і ось його треба навчити
це те про що було згадано сьогодні
безбар'єрність
тому я би
тут говорила про єдину точку збору де ця
людина зранена скалічена але мотивована
може отримати доступ до освітніх послуг
де саме І також Ну мені дуже імпонує
згадана сьогодні книга фільм Список
Шиндлера хто врятує одне життя врятує
весь світ
На жаль ми не зможемо врятувати всіх це
треба об'єктивно прийняти Але ми зможемо
врятувати тих хто хоче бути врятованим І
ось цим мотивованим людям їм потрібно
дати освіту Дякую за увагу
Наталю не можемо врятувати світ це
насправді відносно тому що люди які
пережили Голокосту в них є така
приповідка що коли рятуєш одну людину
територію цілий світ так що насправді
йдеться про сотні тисяч і мільйони
світів і ви почули
шановні як насправді
переживає Наталія Зарицька як
переживають
тисячі десятки тисяч сотні тисяч людей
які опиняються в схожій не в ідентичній
але в дуже схожих ситуаціях бо кожна
ситуація вона
по-своєму виявляється і я прошу з
першого Ірину Шумик а потім Романа
поклонського прокоментувати те що вони
почули від Наталії
мені мабуть пощастило одну хвилинку а ви
шановні можете вже давати знаки Хто з
вас захоче поставити запитання або
зробити репліку Прошу мені пощастило в
лапках 2014 рік я зустріла в
Дніпропетровській Ода і перші
переселенці а потім власне наші
добровольчі загони які пішли одразу в
АТО
і я маю цей гіркий досвід роботи з
військовослужбовцями їх ще тоді не
називали ветеранами які повернулися
власне з того пекла і треба було щось
робити і я абсолютно погоджуюся всіх
врятувати не вдасться На жаль але те що
наші як ми називаємо волнера был групп
тобто ті які постраждали які потребують
додаткової уваги наші співвітчизники
це це не просто знаєте це не має бути
просто наданням послуги тобто коли
людина прийшла А вона часто не знає тут
чи цікаві речі за оздоровленням хтось
хто дуже
ознайомлений з усіма можливостями може
Тричі за рік оздоровлюватись за рахунок
різних програм а хтось Перепрошую
сільською місцевості якщо немає доступу
до ресурсів або йому просто ніколи ніхто
їй не пояснювали
можуть жодного разу не оздоровлюватись
те саме власник третіми послугами
але ми більше я навіть в рамках цього
проекту і в рамках своєї діяльності
Оскільки ми говоримо про професійну
освіту Ми говоримо про створення
можливостей для кожної людини
здобувати освіту або не освіту А окремо
якісь кваліфікації часткові протягом
життя
і чому цей супровід має бути постійним
тому що так як змінилося в один день все
в Україні так власне може змінитися і
завтра ми спочатку або в світі прийшов
ковід в один день і треба було
пристосовуватись зараз війна в нас нам
взагалі
дісталося і треба бути настільки
гнучкими і ця система яку ми разом з
вами будуємо має бути настільки
відкритою як би то не звучало дружньою
до громадянина дружньої до ветерана
дружньої до будь-кого хто до нас
звертається це не просто Я підтверджую
теж 100% ви як в нас немає системи
реабілітації так само ми не готові до
навчання
тих хто пройшов війну і це не тільки до
речі ветерани це що купа людей які
змушені були виїхати чи які вже
примусово виїздили з тих територій
в мене простий приклад ми робили проект
для дітей які виїхали тоді із зони АТО і
для дітей чи її батьки В той момент
воювали це Дніпропетровська область у
нас були одні і інші вони вчилися в
одних класах і там був постійний
конфлікт тому що діти чиї батьки воювали
Вони казали це через вас Мій батько
сьогодні там А ті діти які приїхали Вони
кажуть Ми приїхали з війни з жаху і ми
просто ми Нічого ми взагалі добрі і ми
хочемо жити в Україні і я скажу що в
мене був досвід 4 місяці Я працювала з
цими дітьми підлітками в основному це
дуже непроста історія але те що все
можливо і є відповідні напрацьовані
практики а я думаю що як лікарня
Мечникова сьогодні є однією з кращих по
операціях лікування травм так в принципі
і нам доведеться стати можливо кращими в
світі по подальшій реабілітації наданню
освітніх послуг з огляду тому ми з
колегами з командою проекту про це
говорили і цьому присвячений окремий
напрям роботи в проекті про те що треба
змінювати і це має бути не просто
програма і це має бути не просто
майстерня куди прийде Ветеран Я
перепрошую мене багато прикладів з
Дніпропетровської області бо там дуже
багато моїх колег які зараз працюють
останній приклад закладу освіти який
розташований там треба півтора кілометра
пройти від зупинки так от е-е хлопчина
вже зараз наш Ветеран сьогоднішній
навчаючись на коротких курсах на
айтішніках в одному з нашому закладі
освіти а-а
протест Ну майже Тому що йому треба було
ледь не щодня долати цю відстань а це
означає що нас
чекає і ми потребуємо кардинальних змін
як в середовищі заклади приміщення так І
власне в програмах в підходах і для
цього нам треба буде навчити персонал в
тому числі як працювати в таких складних
обставинах дякую пані Ірино пане Романе
будь ласка ваш коментар і ще ті хто
дивиться нас на Ютубі і в Зумі Ви можете
поставити в чатах запитання мені їх
передадуть тоді якщо вони будуть будь
ласка пане Роман
Так я розумію ускладність цього питання
мінекономіки
формує політику у сфері праці зайнятості
є ще кілька совів які дотичні до цього
питання це все розглядається в комплексі
не
далі ніж учора А у нас була зустріч з
іноземними партнерами які
які трохи
[музика]
дивувалися що у нас в країні функції
центрального органу виконавчої влади які
повинен опікуватися ветеранами вони
розпорошені по різним міністерствам це
недолік Я підтверджую що
одному з міністерств які не присутні
зараз на цій зустрічі їм треба більш
активна
модерувати цю політику
що стосується Міністерства економіки Ми
дуже дуже щільно працюємо зараз з
деякими громадськими організаціями
ветеранськими і за допомогою них До речі
я коли виступали якраз подумала Наталія
що вас треба познайомитись з тими нашими
партнерами за допомогою яких ми
зараз змінюємо законодавство для того
щоб полегшити ветеранам інтегруватись в
робочі в робоче життя
питання комплексне питання яке до якого
повинен долучитися і МОЗ в частині в
частині медичних питань в частині там
медичних оглядів мон частині освіти До
речі Міністерство економіки воно також
має нормативні такти які які перевіряють
рівень знань там
на предмета кваліфікації на предмет
знань охорони праці і ми працюємо над
цифровізації цих процесів і е-е якраз з
приводу того що як ветерану припустимо
сидіти за одною партою якщо у нього там
певні е-е
інстинкти після війни так то це
дистанційна освіта - це онлайн-освіта і
все інше питання питання велике але
слона ж з'їдають по шматочках щоб там не
подивитися ним Тому А це все буде
вирішено
Я думаю що за допомогою тих всіх
міністерств які дотичні до цього ми
зможемо це подавати Дякую пане роману
Наталії є репліка на те що вона почула
після цього запитання з аудиторії
е так віце-прем'єр з реінтеграцією
збирає координаційну Раду але якраз
профільна Міністерство блокують цю
роботу і не хоче брати участь чомусь і є
наприклад як низка позитивних
напрацювань так і низка напрацювань
скажімо Указ Президента номер 576 про
перегляд рішень військово-лікарських
комісій понепридатним якраз
щорічний перегляд буде І от як Ветеран
Да який непридатний вже списаний може
запланувати собі навчання довгострокове
Якщо завтра ну його будуть повертати а
перелік хвороб значно звужений розумієте
про що йдеться тобто тут треба вочевидь
короткострокові
концентровані програми з навчання
впроваджувати Так ми матимемо
суспільство ображених ті хто не виїха
будуть ображатися на тих хто виїхали ті
хто не воювали на тих хто воював і
навпаки уже є Я тебе туди не посылал А
ну це зрозуміло і тут треба зарадити
поставити підставити плечі і ще коротка
Ремарка не всі професії будуть придатні
А це закономірно тому що чоловік він
реалізувався на війні
він там відбувся він народився там як
чоловік як захисник і він отримував
доволі пристойне
матеріальне забезпечення ми зараз за
партнерилися з компаніями які працюють
на оборону але в цивільному житті це
виробники Дронів виробники снарядів вони
готові брати з певними умовами і
розумінням ветеранів але хлопці кажуть Я
не можу піти на виробництво монотонне Я
звик движувати це їхніми словами говорю
і він не готовий іти на 18-20 тисяч
гривень йому треба забезпечу Ось такі
проблеми Дякую дуже запитання від пана у
кремового кольору сорочці мікрофон
залишається в руках Олександра в руці
Олександр
калишка інститут професійної
кваліфікації
мене питання до пані Ганна Резнік
Скажіть будь ласка ну статистика вражає
Власне кажучи 402 центри 150 професій і
людей які отримали сертифікати але
прозвучало у вас фраза про те що вони
працевлаштовані тобто видачі сертифіката
как би дорівнювается працевлаштуванню
хотілося б запитати яким чином ви
відслідковуєте Наскільки ці люди
працевлаштовані наскільки довго не
працевлаштовані і чи не є якихось Скажем
так нарікання бо проблем цій сфері що
вам дає підстави стверджувати що вони
всі працевлаштовані дякуємо дякуємо
прошу Дякую за запитання Шановні колеги
коли я доповідала власне я акцентувала
на тому що сертифікат який видається
кваліфікаційним центром Це очевидно є
допуск до роботи і очевидно що такі
особи можуть бути працевлаштовані наша
комунікація із кваліфікаційними центрами
Таким чином звітують власне щомісяця і
подають нам відомості про присвоєння
підтвердження і професійні кваліфікації
про кількість виданих сертифікатів так
комунікація власне дає нам привід
зробити висновок що власне є запит і
люди які звертаються в кваліфікаційні
центри знаходять в подальшому роботу і
ну власне здійснюють свої всі трудові
функції необхідні
Дякую дякую ще запитання з аудиторії
Та будь ласка ось панна в смугастій
кроватьці будь ласка і я зразу скажу що
в мене ще є принаймні одне запитання до
Наталії горбицької будь ласка прошу вас
Олександр шуфалюк ми минулого року
приймали участь у проектах jaz е-е по
навчанню на робочих місцях і тут є
питання може навіть репліка яка
потребувала в коментаря Ірини Шумик до
вас з одного боку з великою повагою
ставляться в секторі але з іншого боку
Хочеться зробити акцент на певні
проблематиці і почути вашу думку от
реалізується декілька проектів от
Минулого року були успішно доволі на мій
погляд реалізовані проекти gz там і
цього року паралельно Практично за тим
самим дизайном реалізується проекти USD
іншими організаціями і получається що
вони якби починають кожного разу з нуля
і сьогодні ми говорили про необхідність
масштабування позитивного досвіду
успішних історій чи може
результативніше буде І чи наскільки
долучається Ну от і мінеко номіки може
мін е-е Освіти і Науки до того щоб
системно якось опрацьовувати оцей
розвиток
підтримки проектів підтримки освіти щоб
не кожного разу з нуля зараз багато дуже
все зрозуміло Дякую за запитання
навчання власне Не так багато цих
проектів Як ви сказали Якби їх було дуже
багато Ми би були щасливі дійсно те що
закінчилось в рамках програми її у
Forest Kills такі проба-пира в нас щодо
навчання на виробництві е-е з подальшим
можливо походом до кваліфікаційного
центру і підтвердженням кваліфікації і
ми розпочали низку короткотермінових
навчань разом з UNDP і разом з usaid це
настільки коротке навчання які якраз
були організовані для внутрішнього
переміщених осіб і для осіб які
звільнилися з військової служби і
потребували перед навчання
абсолютно не секретна формула вона
стандартна коли
проекти закладом освіти співпрацюють з
роботодавцем визначають потреби
роботодавця роблять коротку програму За
нею навчають і Відповідно ми наших
випускників здобувачів таких часткових
кваліфікацій працевлаштовуємо не 100%
працевлаштування це нормально хтось може
потім знайде себе в іншій компанії чи
десь на ринку плюс-мінус в інший
кваліфікації що стосується обміну
досвідом я вас запевняю що Ми ділимося з
колегами які стартують нові проекти
попередніми напрацюваннями Я з тих людей
яка не любить винаходити велосипеда дві
чи тричі А але дуже прекрасна пропозиція
є тут звертаюсь до команди проекту
найближчим часом тоді організувати нам
якісь круглий стіл або вебінар для того
щоб ще раз з усіма партнерами ці краще
практики обговорити дякую дякую пані
Ірино
по-новому стані змогу поставити
запитання або зробити репліку
нема Наталю
ви говорили і постійно наголошували
чоловіки і чоловіки головна з тисячі
ветеранок є і ще будуть наскільки робота
з ними на вашу думку має бути така сама
або відрізнятись Наскільки Ви знаєте да
от ви тут підкреслювати що чоловік там
зреалізувався і так далі І до речі Іван
Вербицький тут про гендерний аспект
згадував що ви скажете на цю тему
так абсолютно не характерно для жінки
але жінки на фронті жінки отримують
важкі поранення і ну такий яскравий
приклад це Андріана Сусак яка очолювала
жіночі ветеранські рух вона отримала
важке поранення надвишка реабілітації і
теж пошук волонтерами місця де вона
могла би піднятися
тут теж має бути підхід до реабілітації
жінок постраждалих на полі бою і що тут
варто додати що роботодавцям не треба
боятися ветеранів Так є певні проблеми
нюанси але вони здоланні натомість Ви
отримаєте
крутого фахівця з дуже розвиненою
інтуїцією з
вмінням передбачати реакція швидка
миттєва Я не знаю як вони ці хлопці і
дівчата інтуїтивно навіть повітряні
тривоги вони відчувають їх за пів години
тобто це будуть достойні працівники а
Уявіть що Якщо це жінка які якою в
природи закладено
керувати материнство організовувати
тобто тут будуть ще й сильні сторони
дуже маленька репліка стосовно жінок не
тільки
ветеранок А у нас насправді в окремих
регіонах є є наявна ситуація коли
фахівці в чоловічої статі вони в
основному призвані там мобілізовані
натомість підприємства страждають від
нестачі і ми вже сьогодні починаємо
роботу над тим щоб популяризувати
традиційну чоловічі як ми це називаємо
професії для жінок от дуже простий
приклад одне з аграрних підприємств
Миколаївської області Зараз збирає групу
дівчат для навчання на трактористок
тобто ну інакше просто немає Хтось має
виїжджати в поле і якщо немає чоловіків
то будемо шукати жінок то це теж такий
окремий напрямок і виклик для проекту
дякую пані Ірино наш час на цій частині
роботи добігає кінця тому що незабаром у
нас буде
учасниця аж із самої Латвії у нас
залишається дві хвилини і ну переберемо
1,5 хвилини тому що у кожної кожного з
вас зараз буде по 30 секунд на те щоб
сказати
які слова які ви тут почули
запам'яталися вам найбільше і чому і
почне цього разу Іван Вербицький
я хочу сказати про те що час після воїну
в Європі після першої другої світової
війни це обласна був той час який став
стимулом для утворення політик
пов'язаних з боротьбою з безробіттям і
зайнятістю і це той час коли поштовх був
настільки великим що держава не мали
іншого вибору як реагувати і
вигадувати ті речі які для нас зараз
виглядають очевидними як наприклад
допомога по безробіттю чи центри
зайнятості але вони були винайдені після
воїн власне і зараз ми будемо те що в
цій ситуації коли нам потрібно буде
шукати нові способи як долати ті виклики
з якими ми стикаємося одне слово на
якому я би хотів запитувати це слово
турбота бо ми багато говорили про
ініціативність і про те що власне
люди які спілкуються 30 секунд збігли
Денис Олійник
Дякую я хотів відповісти пані Наталі
стосовно ми як служба зайнятості дуже
чітко розуміємо ситуація яка складається
з ветеранами до нас вже є звернення ми
розуміємо
щоб тебе наші працівники були гнучкі як
кажуть пані Ірина при надані цих послуг
і якщо сказати що в нас вже працює
програма гранти для ветеранів в нас вже
близько 300 заяв на отримання ну коштів
для власної справи тому
безумовно спілкуватися і щоб від вас
почути конкретні оці ризики при надання
нами пане Денисе Роман поклонський
робота рятує рятує від лінії від застою
а для того щоб її отримати треба
навчатися тому
навчаємось розвиваємось і і все і не
будемо сумувати ага нарезнік
Шановні колеги здається сьогодні
найчастіше звучало слово все ж таки
відновлення звичайно Воно включає в себе
різні компоненти і з того що ми сьогодні
з вами почули тут ми однозначно маємо
об'єднатися для досягнення спільної мети
У кожного з нас Своє бачення
свої шляхи вирішення певних проблем тому
для того щоб нам дійти спільного
знаменника має можна зустрічатись і
проговорювати проблемні питання і шляхи
їх вирішення Дякую Ірина Шумик
для мене Можливо воно менше звучало але
це все ж таки виклик я не люблю слова
проблема Я люблю слово виклик ми його
обов'язково подолаємо і Хочу додати
процитувати от бачу тут Петра
Миколайовича
слова Віталія Коваля голови Рівненської
обласної військової адміністрації про те
що зайняті руки ніколи не опускаються Я
думаю що так у нас і буде Дякую Наталія
горбицька
Я сьогодні зранку звірилася з чоловіком
кажу іду на такий важливий захід який
будуть побажання він каже Наталка явно
буде тривати державну політику культуру
ставлення до військових поприси будь
ласка щоб було ставлення до особливих
людей таке щоб вони себе не відчували
особливими
а шановні на цьому обговорення тут
закінчилось можна проходити тепер до
зали повертатися
звичайно обговорення триватиме і в
кулуарах і в процесі роботи Головне що
робота вже почалася насправді бо
аналізи де миттєвий дії
уже
розпочинаються і ми відчуваємо на собі
наскільки важливо міжнародна співпраця
недарма ж взагалі цей проєкт Він
організований німецьким товариством
міжнародної співпраці і зараз почуємо
пані і у були інована керівниця
Департаменту в Міністерстві освіти
Латвії розповість про свій досвід і про
те як напевно з Латвії видно Україну а
ми були
вам пані були
всі уважно вас слухаємо
Доброго ранку Шановні колеги дуже
пишаюся запрошенням виступити перед
такою
шановна аудиторія тільки велике велике
виправлення я на голова департаменту я
старшого експерт Але тим не менше маю
тривалий досвід роботи в мін освіти
Латвії
зокрема і до часу з часу приєднання
Латвії до ЄС і до того
Я також є науковим співробітником
вузу Латвію і займаюся дослідженням
сфери профтехосвіти є членом робочих
груп з питань про техосвіти і також До
речі комітету з профтехосвіти
у 2022 році мала Щасливий шанс
попрацювати з українськими колегами щодо
реформування системи профтеху освіти в
Україні
і я Хотіла б звернутися до слів
висловлених представників організації
жінки зі сталі це дійсно дуже важливо
для майбутньої України
власна реформа в Україні зараз реформи в
профтехосвіті є практично паралельно
тому що робиться з аналогічними
реформами у ЄС Тому
очевидно не мені рекомендувати вам як
рухатися далі тим не менше ми маємо
певний досвід який ми набрали після
приєднання до ЄС і можливо цей буде
досвід корисним як і кілька прикладів
які я готова навести Отже ми
приєдналися до ЄС 2004 року і майже
одразу ми змогли використовувати
можливість
використання структурних фондів ЄС
зокрема фонду регіонального розвитку
які стосувався допомоги в
інфраструктурному розвитку матеріальному
забезпеченні і розвитку людського
капіталу
відповідно до
політики фонду регіонального розвитку
був створений відповідний підрозділ для
роботи зі структурними фондами при
міністерстві явишла до числа працівників
і фактично зараз вже 20 років майже
минуло
і Це дало дуже результати нашого закладу
зокрема профтехосвіти вони Практично всі
зазнали глибоку реконструкцію вони
сучасні вони
принадні вони користуються попитом і це
дійсно важливо на рівні всієї Європи
дуже актуальним є питання Престижу про
тих освіти його підвищення
така допомога від ЄС допомогла нам із
відповідною
реформою цілує сфери це те про що колеги
говорили сьогодні це стосується і
кращого реагування на потреби ринку я
забезпечити
конкурентоспроможність випускників і
їхніх навичок знань кваліфікації
головне питання
полягало
у тому як перейти на компетентнісні
підхід
на основі зокрема кредитної системи
завдяки такої гнучкової системи ви
можете краще реагувати на запити і
потреби ринку праці
і також малими реформу з містовою
частини профтехосвіти яка зайняла у нас
десь 10 років
самі зміни які були напрацьовані
буквально 18
сторінок зайняла до законодавчої бази і
це стосувалося усіх аспектів освіти
мікрокредитів і так далі змістової
частини доступ доступу освіти для тих
хто навчається
з точки зору політики наші сильні
сторони в тому що ми налагодили міцний
соціальний діалог
ми маємо Раду роботодавців
з якогось співпрацю відповідні
міністерствами представники
мінекономикими
праці там регулярні зустрічі
відбуваються раз на місяць для
обговорення усіх питань і проблемних
моментів
тобто таке засідання передбачають
осучаснення усіх інституційних
механізмів які дозволяють реагувати
на подібні проблеми
І це те що робиться не на папері а в
реальному житті
дуже важливим елементом є освіта для
дорослих і є відповідно також рада яка
активно займається регулярним переглядом
основної проблематики для освіти
дорослих з урахуванням потреб робочої
сили
не можу сказати що ми всю роботу вже
завершили А ми активно рухаємося у цьому
напрямку
також треба ще раз нагадати реформу на
основі запровадження
компетентнісного підходу
є певні нюанси зокрема пов'язані із
цифровізацією профтехосвіти Ми дуже
багато чого робимо І власне
Я вже чим пишатися ми зробили
вертикальну горизонтально картування
всієї галузі профтехосвіти це дуже
ефективно допомагає кар'єрному розвитку
і появі нових кваліфікації це все
робиться у тісній співпраці з нашими
партнерами на ринку праці
це допомагає Як з точки зору освітньої
частини так і з точки зору подальшого
працевлаштування випускників
рухаючись далі ми презентацію хочу
сказати ще раз що дійсно ми змогли
модернізувати профтег заклади
[музика]
і ми будемо радіо гостити українських
колег Для
навчальних візитів наша Міністерство
готове організувати такий поїздки
зустріч але Дозвольте
приклад навести який стосується одного з
пріоритетом Тобто це загрожує групи
в
завершальній частині моє промови я
розкажу
про компонент проекту від якого ми
очікували такого
успіху
цей компонент називається
пульс це попередження
випадіння з
професійної освіти
студентів які вступили на таку
професійну освіту а в Латвії це
вважається що
це дуже важливе такий проект розпочався
5 років
тому і на той момент ми були єдиними в
Євросоюзі хто розпочав таку політику на
оцінному на національному рівні Ми
отримали підтримку від єврокомісії
які ж успіхи цього проекту звичайно ми
не стільки вразливі ситуації як багато
українців зараз але і у нас є соціально
вразлива молоді Яка кидає навчання і ми
охопили цим
проектом всі
професійні школи в Латвії де
молоді люди навчаються їх вчителі
і розробили
спеціальну методологію ми
розділили вразливих студентів на
категорії ті хто пережили фізичну травму
або мають соціальні проблеми у родині ті
хто зазнали травматичного життєвого
досвіду і відповідно до кожного
до потреб кожної групи ми розробили
Заходи які можна запропонувати для
подолання наслідків травми потім ми
підготували вчителів і наставників які
не просто навчають таких людей але і
відкриті для допомоги їм можуть надати
кваліфіковану допомогу будь-який час
доби і для таких людей ми розробили
також спеціальні навчальні курси І що
дуже важливо Я хочу розповісти про
інноваційні Досвід цього проекту разом
із латвійським телебаченням ми розробили
спеціальні телевізійні програми які
були записані ці програми на конкретні
теми як жити без батьків як змінити
школу як жити з травми і це програми для
молоді і в кожній такій програмі
[музика]
молоді із такими досвідом вони
добровільно розповіли про своє життя як
вони дають собі раду із цим І коли це
було показано по центральному
латвійському телебаченні вся країна
побачила ці проблеми люди почали їх
обговорювати
зрозуміло що бувають такі травми про які
молодь люди які потерпають від них вони
соромляться говорити вони не хочуть це
обговорювати але
варто
допомогти таким людям щоб вони не кидали
навчання щоб для них була надія на
майбутнє і ми розповсюджували інформацію
про наш проект що ми відкриті для
дискусій що ми відкриті до обміну
досвідом
І що ще дуже важливо як дослідник я
долучилася до
дослідження що проводиться в
університеті Латвії
ми охопили дослідженням тих вчителів які
працюють з такими вразливими
студентами і Це дало нам просто
безцінний досвід тому що метою проекту
було
попередити випадіння із навчання
вразливих
призливих молоді підлітків і
після проведення широкомасштабних
інтерв'ю ми виявили наступне що
більшість вразливих студентів почали
краще навчатися в результаті вжитих нами
заходів ніж а навіть не вразливі
студенти і
також досвід показав що під час
інтерв'ю з цими студентами
ми дізналися що в результаті
проекту вони відчули себе більш впевнено
більш незалежними дехто почав говорити я
хочу стати підприємцем я
ставлю перед собою такі інші цілі і Ми
зрозуміли що це
виліковує відразливості так би сказати
звичайно знов підкреслюю Латвія не в
такій складній ситуації як Україна зараз
але це демонструє що
також
може бути цікавий досвід який може стати
у нагоді Україні
у тій важкій ситуації в якій ви
знаходитеся І я хочу завершуючи
подякувати ще раз щоб ви мене запросили
і дали можливість поділитися досвідом
нашого
Міністерства досвідом Латвії
який ви можливо захочете використати А
ми залишаємося відкритими до будь-якого
у досвідом і готові надати такі
візити навчальний які можуть видатися
вам корисними Дякую дуже
приємно було спостерігати за позитивним
досвідом який з такою усмішкою добро
виклали і
Ми дуже
вдячній латвійському народу за вашу
підтримку Солідарність постійної з
українцями і ми
намагатимося зробити Все від нас залежне
щоб в майбутньому нашому спілкуванні ви
продовжували так лагідно усміхатися у
нас ще із міжнародним баченням розвитку
України Тетяна Білецька вона керівниця
групи підтримки реформ у Міністерстві
освіти та науки України
пані Тетяну
показують що не буде пані Тетяни
пані Тетяна Прекрасна
Ні ну що ви так вам буде зручнішим і
головне що публіка вже звикла дивитися в
цей бік там будь ласка планети Дякую
дуже Вітаю всіх А ви знаєте учора мені
колеги поставили питання Що для мене є
одні з найважливіших Я люблю таке ж
слово як пані Ірина шум як виклики або
челендж з англійською тому що воно і
позитивне і негативне може бути
одночасно і підштовхує нас до розвитку у
процесі європейської інтеграції і через
те що я працюю вже з 19-го року у
команді підтримки реформ Міністерства
освіти і науки ми у тому числі
допомагаємо реалізації реформи
професійної освіти Я якраз з питаннями
спілкування з міжнародними партнерами з
розвитку і з питаннями Явір інтеграції
постійно стикаюся і мені здається одним
з викликів є тут
розуміння спільне і
таких речей які є наскрізними концепції
дуже важливими для процесу
євроінтеграції і відповідно певні зміни
у свідомості у менталітеті за ці роки що
я працюю я побачила наприклад що як це
не дивно може і закономірна під час
війни
деякі процеси дуже сильно прискорилися
наприклад сприйняття ролі професійної
освіти у процесі навчання протягом життя
І підготовці перепідготовці дорослого
населення просто перейшло на інший
рівень протягом буквально першого року
повномасштабної війни
міняються інші концепти але
Враховуючи те про що ми сьогодні всі
говорили я б хотіла звернути ще увагу на
такий концепт інклюзивність освіти
у нас в Україні іноді це більше обмежено
до моменту забезпечення
навчальних послуг для людей з особливими
освітніми потребами для людей з
інвалідністю але
інклюзивність освіти суспільства Мені
здається зараз ще більш актуально стає і
в аспекті розуміння різних
маргіналізованих або тих груп які не є
зараз всі разом груп населення
забезпечення через освіту їх єдності
бачення
єдиного українського
і на окупованих територіях і для
переміщених осіб і для тих українців Хто
зараз не знаходиться в Україні і тут є
дуже великий челендж Мені здається на
шляху євроінтеграції Тому що тут може
мінятися сприйняття не тільки України
під час євроінтеграції але й країн
членів процес тому що
в країнах ЄС з моменту Другої світової
війни якщо ми кажемо про східну або
Центральну Європу не було такої ситуації
як я У нас для країн Західної Європи з
моменту Першої
світової війни не було такої ситуації
вони не завжди можуть зрозуміти що
переживає наше суспільство і на такий
момент як
інклюзивність А тих українців які зараз
не живуть в Україні може бути абсолютно
різний погляд з боку країн наприклад
Німеччини і Західної Європи вони
зацікавлені в цій робочій силі і в тому
щоб ці люди отримали якісь кваліфікації
і залишилося як робоча сила працювати в
їхніх країнах А у нас в Україні навпаки
є завдання максимум людей повернути або
хоча б якщо вони в плані діалектики
інклюзивності і мобільності мають право
і зможуть знаходитися особливо коли
Україна приєднається до ЄС і працювати в
інших країнах який їх внесок для власної
країни економічний
в плані розвитку людського капіталу все
одно може бути це абсолютно унікальний
якийсь особлива для умовно кажучи старих
країн ЄС і Європи на даний момент Ну і
Мені здається це те про що треба думати
вже зараз і є сенс обговорювати дуже
дякую пані Тетяно два запитання виходячи
з того що ви сказали а по-перше Ми
багато говоримо про інклюзивність сусіди
але щось мені дуже рідко доводиться чути
про інклюзивність роботи будь ласка про
це
ну Сьогодні ми до цього теж
зверталися про питання інклюзивності
ринку праці
це напряму пов'язана з системою саме
професійної освіти вона говорити про
професійно ви маєте на увазі те що в мої
роки називалося
професійно-технічною професійно-техні
на те що було непрестижним називали
бурсу чи ще якось чим жахали дітей якщо
вони погано будуть вчитися в школі то
далі ПТУ вони нікуди не підуть а тут я і
кажу що у нас зараз міняється парадигма
і ми розуміємо що
потреби ринку праці змінюються настільки
швидко і ковід - війна в нашій країні це
прискорили ковід - це у всьому світі
пояснив нам Наскільки швидко людям треба
утримувати мене на вік кваліфікації
скіли і іноді безформальної освіти це не
так важливо головне Як Доміно складати
якісь нові навички чи знання які
потрібні прямо зараз і вже ніхто не може
отримати професію на все життя але в
Україні ще й війна наклалася на цей
повномасштабна війна процес і тому я
вважаю що Україна має унікальний досвід
і ось процес євроінтеграції з точки зору
змін в освіті і навчанні впродовж життя
і в ринках праці він буде такий яким І
ми можемо ділитися і можна у нас вивчати
а не тільки ми повинні дотягнути до
якихось стандартів щоб стати частиною
краї Ну я не можу
інклюзивність ринку праці від
інклюзивності процесу навчання дорослих
для себе Я не так маю на увазі ринок
праці з інклюзивництво як уже його
результат тобто Люди які працюють так
уже працюють не ті які шукають Ну то
таке будемо працювати Будемо бачити і
друге запитання у дискусії і обговорення
питання повернення українок і українців
там не повернення і формування у нас
робочої сили дуже рідко лунає питання
про міграцію до України з інших країн
що син наскільки ми не тільки можемо а й
маємо розраховувати на це Адже
незважаючи на війну умови в Україні досі
залишаються привабливішими ніж в деяких
країнах Азії наприклад я не можу себе
Мене звати експерт в цій сфері Але тим
не менше з моменту повномасштабного
вторгнення я пройшла один навчальний
курс міжнародної організації праці який
якраз стосується створення умов для
вимушена переміщених осіб різного типу
мігрантів і
з тих азів які я вивчала на цьому курсі
я зрозуміла краще
чому деякі країни свідомо залучають
людський капітал з інших країн а якщо ми
виходимо з реальності з тих де гірші
умови знову ж таки вже такий є класичний
досвід Німеччини яка відкрила ну
Невдовзі після Другої світової війни
свій ринок праці для Гаста і барти
арбайтерів тобто для людей які є
гостьовими працівниками таким же чином
дуже вірогідно доведеться діяти батькам
Ми бачили на початку презентації проекту
кількість робочої сили можна було
зрозуміти цифри якою нам не вистачає
крім того у нас одна з найбільших країн
за
площиною але вона не буде населена
об'єктивна і теж населення старіє і ще у
нас є інші демографічні зміни з
інвалідизацією населення спричинення У
нас такого вибору іншого Я думаю Я думаю
це повинно бути з одним виборів і тоді
для освіти виклик бути готовими теж
визнавати цих кваліфікації і надавати
освітні послуги для мігрантів у тому
числі з азійських країн і це і
викладання різними мовами і знов же таки
інші ще аспект інклюзивності - це прям
ціле коло питань для яких я думаю
потрібні окремі платформи для
обговорення і можливо навіть спеціальні
проекти Дуже дякую пані Тетяно Тетяна
Білецька керівниця групи підтримки
реформ у Міністерстві освіти і науки
України і ще до нас приєднується зараз
пан Михайло Лещенко і з посольство
Німеччини Ось він будь ласка слухаємо
пане лещенка
Для мене велика честь бути сьогодні тут
і передати вам всім привітання від
посольства Німеччини побажати цьому
проекту успіху в найближчий терміни
Німеччина підтримує Україну спочатку
української незалежності підтримка
реформ процесів реформування різних сфер
українського життя розпочалася задовго
до 22-го року задовго до початку
великомасштабної агресії Росії задовго
до 14-го року Коли фактично розпочалася
війна Росії з Україною
весь цей час одним із на сьогоднішній
день Німеччина є одним з найбільших
донорів
і країн які не дадуть політичну
підтримку Україні
весь цей час
Німецька
гезера
Товариство з міжнародної співпраці вона
стало
добре відомим
інструментом цієї співпраці в Україні з
великим досвідом роботи в Україні і які
саме найголовніше
завоював
здобув довіру українських органів
державної влади українських підприємців
українських людей і дуже часто ми чуємо
паралельно що там Німеччина і гітц
навіть через кому це каже про ту велику
роль яку відіграє ця агенція тут в
Україні як інструмент німецької
технічної допомоги тут в Україні
Ну ми дуже часто чуємо що бюрократія
працює досить повільно але я хочу в
цьому випадку конкретному випадку
відмітити як швидко гітц вдалося разом з
українськими партнерами підготувати цей
проект розпочати цей проект і я
сподіваюся що в найближчим часом ми вже
побачимо Його перший результат оскільки
як мені керівники проекту казали вже ну
до кінця цього року на початку
Наступного року ми маємо згенерувати
перші результати про які можна буде
звітувати і найбільша частина тих
фінансових ресурсів які залучені в цей
проект має бути витрачено якомога швидше
це було зроблено для Німеччини для
німецької підходу до таких проектів які
плануються мінімум на 3-4 роки ну це
велике досягнення хочу вам сказати і
коли п Андрію Ви питали яка українська
прислів'я спадає людям на думку то я
хочу сказати от моя рефлексія була доки
грім не гряне дядько на перехреститься
Ну там в українській версії був не
дядько але я маю сказати саме Так ви
знаєте перехрестилися не тільки Україна
а Вся Європа і весь світ
і це якраз вказує на те що в Німеччині
відбулися фундаментальні зміни щодо
відношення
безпекових питань щодо допомоги України
і оцей перший приклад як швидко геїцид
відреагувало на цю необхідність
продовжувати посилювати пришвидчувати
реформи в освітянському секторі в
секторі професійної освіти в тому числі
вони показують що це Швидко Все
змінюється
останньому виступати дуже тяжко всі вже
все сказали
з одного боку нема чого самому сказати а
з іншого боку хочеться рефлексія якось
відреагувати на дуже важливі пункти які
були озвучені попередніми тому я спробую
дуже коротко це сказати
технологічний прогрес останніх
десятиліть
призвів до появи нових професій нових
видів діяльності нових ринків нових
бізнесів і це було драйвером за останні
десятиріччя для європейських країн на
індустріальних країн розпочати процес
наскрізного
наскрізної освіти а lifecell
в європейських країнах в країнах Великої
сімки вже накопичений за останні
десятиліття
воєнний стан в Україні це жорстока війна
вона і потреба в такій освіті вона
існувала і до початку війни в Україні
Україна є індустріальною державою
Україна відповідає світовим трендам
Україна економічно розвиненою державою
тому те що відбувається у всьому світі
відбувається у нас Подивіться на своє
Айфони Подивіться на цифровізацію До
речі яка в Україні
випереджає певні
процеси які в Німеччині навіть
відбувається але в Україні виникла своя
специфіка і саме завдяки цьому грому
який грянув 22-му році а саме це
необхідність а
інклюзивної освіти яке має тривати все
життя це необхідність залучення
тимчасово переміщених осіб з огляду на
зміни в регіональному розподілі праці і
так далі я хочу сказати що в цьому
проекті це буде одним із акцентів і мені
хоче сказати що цей проект багатий не
тільки українських фахівців а німецькі
фахів і фахівцям з інших європейських
країн буде чому повчитися саме в цьому
акценті тому що там драйвером був
технологічний прогрес а тут кризове
ситуація ця кризова ситуація вимагає від
нас дуже швидких рішень
німецький досвід як показав проект
попередник і у фоскілс а саме німецький
досвід Ну так званої дуальної освіти або
залучення підприємств залучення бізнесу
до професійної освіти він також буде
корисним і в Україні і я від попередніх
виступаючих Я дуже багато чув що саме це
питання Ну буде одним із інтенсивних
буде інтенсивно вивчатися і
досліджуватися і впроваджуватися в
рамках цього проекту
ще один момент який я би хотів
наприкінці відмітити це співпраця зараз
на цьому етапі Двох українських
міністерств Міністерство економіки та
Міністерство освіти а хочу сказати в
Німеччині та ж не дуже просто зібрати
два Міністерства до купи і зробити
якийсь Спільний проект з огляду на те що
було піднято питання для повернення
проблеми переселення
тимчасове переміщених осіб та людей із
особливими потребами як військових так і
цивільних зрозуміло що бажано було б щоб
і Міністерство реінтеграції
Міністерство ветеранів також були яким
чином долучені до цього проекту або яким
чином його підтримували тому що питання
які піднімали попередні спікери щодо
долі ветеранів їх інтеграції ну це
питання які не можна вирішити в рамках
якогось ну одного до мену одного якогось
органа державної влади тут має бути
державна політика яка працює на всіх і
от в цьому питанні і є Чому повчитися у
німецьких фахівців і є Чому повчитися в
Україні як результати швидкого втілення
і партнерам із Європейського Союзу
останній акцент який хоче зробити і про
це ми чуємо дуже часто і це питання яке
Навіть зараз обговорювалося тут це
повернення українців в Україну я хочу
сказати трошки ширше поставити це
питання і сказати про повернення
українців до професійного життя не до ну
проведу приклад залозі науки багато
науковців не можуть продовжувати
займатися наукою з огляду на те що немає
інфраструктури вона була зруйнована або
ті науковці які виїхали зараз в
Європейські країни вони там з огляду
якихось причин не знайшли собі місця в
університетах чи в науково-дослідних
інститутах і зараз змушені або
отримувати соціальну допомогу або кому
повезло знайти якісь собі Джоб якусь
професію працювати там але ця людина в
яку вкладалося 20 років як мінімум
навчання освіти підвищення кваліфікації
для свого домену науково-досліджень вона
є втраченою це не брейн-дрейн це
брейн-вейс це Вейс Brain а таких питань
в будь-якій галузі це стосується лікарів
вчителів яких до речі зараз також багато
закордоном працюють Тобто це питання
повернення людей до їх професійної
діяльності
і оцей проект Мені здається який
відкриває можливості для підвищення
кваліфікації для перенавчання освоєння
нових професій також і для дорослих
людей які вже мають свою попередню
освіту як професійну так і вищу освіту А
може хтось має вже і доктор тільки за
якимсь фахом це такий перший крок як
дати можливість людям повернутися в
професійне висококваліфіковане
професійне життя звичайно
ще інший був
кількох мітінг і ви запустили тут
дискусію що вам впадає на думку Так от
це от стало таким кількох в тому числі і
для того щоб подумати яким чином
використовувати той людський ресурс який
є в Україні і які треба умови створити
щоб цей ресурс повернувся в Україну і
повернувся свою професійну діяльність
Ну думаю я свій час Дуже дякую пане
Михайло Дякуємо І настав той час коли я
знову запрошую Міхаеля Пауля
для того щоб підбити підсумок
сьогоднішнього і сказати заключне слово
знаменшим натхненням ніж він представляв
проєкт
Я сиджу між вами Сподіваюся це нормально
Дякуємо за ці дві години інтенсивних
дискусій ми почали з обговорень потреб
про інку праці говорили про
також потреби в системі профтехосвіти Ми
дуже глибоко обговорили питання
загрожених груп навіть зробили такий
огляд міжнародними
партнерів цієї роботи і мене лишається
Лише кілька коротких повідомлень для вас
перше проект запущено і наша команда
грунтовно працюватиме щоб
вже до першої нашої дати контрольної 1
листопада щоб у нас уже були перші
результати з нашими пілотами регіонами з
нашими 20-ма питанзи хочу погодитися з
тим що сказав Дмитро загородним
виклики неабияки ми маємо докласти всіх
зусиль щоб на них відповісти і ми разом
з німецьким урядом з усіма колегами
готовий це зробити і останнє вже більш
таке персональне висновок від мене хоче
подякувати Наталі за коментарі
Які ви зробили я дійсно визнаю
необхідність дуже особливої уваги
щодо роботи з цією особливою групою з
них досвіду візитів моїх до Полтави до
Вінниці ми будемо готувати викладачів як
працювати з такими групами загрожуємо ми
будемо фінансово підтримувати такі
тренінги і будемо також кар'єрне
консультантів готувати
наші дискусія свідчать що дуже багато
ще потрібно зробити чи то медичній сфері
чи то сфері психологічної допомоги і ми
в рамках програми профтехосвіти будемо
намагатися якомога тісніше співпрацювати
з іншими учасниками
для того щоб напрацювати позитивні
результати нашої роботи з відповідною
медичною психологічною підтримкою ми
маємо знайти ці ниточки ці зв'язки це
завдання для нашого покоління
забезпечити належну співпрацю між усіма
учасниками органами центральної влади
міністерством України міжнародними
партнерами це питання дійсно інтеграції
наших зусиль не лише для користі
ветеранів але і інших загрожених груп І
наостанок лишається лише запросити вас
до подальшого вже неформального
спілкування під час обідньої перекуски
дякую
міхеля Дуже дякую всім за участь дякую
ще А Руслану який організовував
від режисуру Андрію який відповідав за
звук і
на закінчення хочу сказати таке от в
англійській версії та й в українській
Skills for covery злитно проміжки нема
чи то так проміжків як я навчився в
Київському метрі
і далі читаєш український текст Бачиш що
там теж групи населення написано з Липно
важливе зараз написано злитно а це
означає що час Не чекає це означає що
треба комплексно треба водночас і треба
успішно як ми працювали сьогодні всім
спасибі Ну якщо вже там про українські
народні
приповідки на цьому слові Бувайте
здорові все
[оплески]